Okay.
What happens when you're facing by something that you really don't understand?
Partly what happens is each of who you partner,
why you don't hear any popping up,
all sorts of dramatic theories about what they might have.
Really be humble,
right?
There's paranoia and doubt and cynicism and bitterness and all of that,
but that's your right hemisphere time,
naked picture of reality into generating these fantasies.
Trying to come up with an account that makes sense of what happened and that's
the way the company cope with radically new information.
Something like that,
except the TV more complicated,
and I'm telling you all this because I want to specify how is what.
I want to specify why it's necessary to go to the deepest level of analysis and
to try to understand what's there.
The more mysterious something is,
the more you have to use your imagination.
In some senses it's representative because you do need to,
what did you fantasize and hypothesize about?
Gaffney dream.
Okay,
you'll this office,
but dreams
concentrated on what we eat.
So the part of your brain tells me,
hey,
some things in the normal world,
but that doesn't work perfectly because what you know doesn't work perfectly.
And so you started recruiting errors along the way and then your right
hemisphere collects those areas.
It starts to try to figure out what to do about them.
If you wait,
people have on their CP and the dreaming,
the most common emotion they related to his anxiety and it's because at night
what you do is tried to reconfigure what you know to take into account what you
don't know.
And that's an anxiety provoking process and use notion with regards to dream
analysis,
it was the same with sport to some degree was that you could,
if people were facing an attractable mystery,
they didn't know how to proceed.
So for example,
then you come and see me,
you're not happy in your job that you don't want to give it up because of the
security or like it's a complicated situation and you can't see any way forward.
Then I might say,
well do you dream?
And if you said yes,
some people drink a lot.
And remember it.
And we might take a look at your dreams to see if he could catch the new story
that's emerging Hunter d your knowledge about where it is that you might go.
And that can be very,
very illuminating and people differ in the complexity and sophistication of
their drinks and their ability to remember that.
But we also might fucking your fantasies.
So maybe know you have your fantasy about what you really liked to say to your
boss and it's a fairly Weldon,
I'm seeing in your head embarrassed about it because it's kind of violence and
well,
tell me about the fantasy.
Do you lay it out?
That's fine.
We can take weekend at the seeds of who you might be calm because maybe you're
in,
I'm standing up for yourself and not for your boss.
It's time to retire,
right?
And so you have this fantasy that you rooted in the then ladies out at the
landscape of what look like if you find it,
you just got up enough courage to march in there and say exactly what you had to
say.
And so that's something you want.
And if you're thinking about changing careers and we want to figure out what you
want,
and so she can look up when you're fantasizing about what you wanted,
maybe you could find some seeds of what you want.
You might say,
well,
you're not going to be happy in the next job regardless of what you do unless
you become somewhat more assertive because he was just carried the same problem
into your next jobs would be the problem.
And the problem is this,
that you're not doing enough of what you really need to do to thrive in work and
you can try to solve that problem.
And then we started figuring out whether that would also mean that you would
have to shift careers.
And so that's how you can use to be analysis of say,
fantasies and dreams to shed light on,
on how it is that the person might conduct themselves.
No,
this is where it gets tricky.
Casey hasn't got treats,
Huh?
All right.
So here's another way that you can figure out how to act in the world.
Let's say your your child,
and there's a lot here.
So how do you handle that?
Well,
you stay the simplified environment,
right?
You don't crawl out onto the street with your 10 months old.
Parents aren't like you do that.
They keep you in.
The family did and they keep you close to them.
And what you do is,
you know,
which isn't very much mostly it's how quick things in your vote and investigate
cause that's her,
that's what kids do.
And at the smiling kids to play a little bit,
but it's a frat house piece of knowledge and it's easily disrupted.
And when it's disrupted,
you cry.
And that's a signal of the disruption.
And then your parents move in.
If they're a greater knowledge and they fix whatever the problems and what you
do is you watch and imitate what I'd like you to know what the rep can you,
cause you're not sophisticated enough to know what they're up to.
No child can you give a full town with the behavior of the parents?
No.
Parents should give a full account of her own.
Me.
You certainly country expect that from a child.
But children obviously grow up to take care of their own children.
Just like animals grow up to take care of their own offspring,
never knowing what they're doing.
Exactly.
So you learn by mutation and what that means is that collectively we've faced
things that we didn't understand for very,
very long period of time and we've figured out how to act so that it works.
But we don't know.
We don't know the rules that underlie that makes up you don't know exactly what
that means.
We just figured it out.
So there's was a way of being a good product.
Let's say there's a way being a good mother,
mostly you understand what that is.
We you fail.
Or when your child,
he accuses you of failing at it,
right?
Because it's only in the failure that you realized that you deviate from
whatever the ideal is because you're not,
who the hell knows what the rules are for being a good father?
It's very difficult to detail them,
but you know when you failed.
Okay,
so you know how to be a controlling and you know that because you imitated your
father.
And he indicated his father,
his father,
and it's like waiting way back as far as you can possibly joke.
That's the rule.
We also know that,
and here's,
here's an example of what have a cloth called colleague at the University of
Toronto who spends a maternal behavior tracks and you're actually very
sophisticated.
They have somewhat of a cultural state pass on through imitators.
But if you take rap cops away from their mother and,
and,
and treat the Webinar so that they live in,
which is not that easy,
by the way is feeding them and giving them enough water and warmth and so forth
isn't enough.
You also have to attend it to them.
You have to touch the plaintiff and won't they die anyways.
If you take the rep hops away from their mother and then you let those routes
grow up and after round tops and then those that grow up and have red pumps,
et Cetera,
you find that the maternal behavior is disruptive for three generations.
So that shows you why you need that imitative continuity in order to keep
knowledge that's implicit propagating into a culture.
So once it's disruptive,
it's very difficult to locals once again ask.
So
we've learned how to be good and bad by trial and error for very long periods of
time.
We've learned that with imaging that from the people that we see who are good
and bad,
we've learned how to embody that.
And so we carry that with us in our actions.
Now you actually include this in quite a sophisticated way,
even though if you can't describe it exactly.
So let's say you go to a party and there's someone that gets annoying and
they're annoying because they tell jokes that aren't funny and they've been help
license conversation and,
and they don't pay any attention to anyone else because they're full of micro
errors.
That made me socially tolerable.
And so what,
what they are doing is easy.
Anything from her in person,
right?
That's why they were annoying,
obviously,
because they're not engaging the way they should be hated.
And you can tell that because they're annoying.
And so what that means is that you have an ideal that you're expecting from
other people all the time.
That that isn't the case.
Because wherever we go,
we meet people and we expect that they will act out the ideal.
And when they don't want we knows.
But that doesn't mean you can say what it is cause you know you might go home
with your partner and say I was that person.
So in the way,
and then you guess a bunch out.
Right.
But it's hard to specify it because you don't move the ideal that you don't know
exactly what it was to break through.
It's very difficult to meet this articulate,
but you do have the an ideal in mind.
Okay.
So what that means is stuff we can act out and conceptualizing this deal before
we could describe the words what that ideal he is.